and that's why nakamura retreats this
rook you look surprised by that one
no i know i'm not surprised i'm just
trying to work out like
what to do next for white i mean do i
step forward with the king yes he's done
that king of the hill king in the center
of the board looking proudly looking
good and
now the knight comes to over protect his
sibling sibling um
again
there's no clear-cut kind of winning
attempt by uh for a niche
yeah that's set up the barriers the
blockade he's just trying to hope that
there's no breakthrough
well one thing that i was thinking about
doing is maybe retreating with my bishop
with the bishop just to kind of clear
the second row
yeah
and okay
okay so
do we takes some action and
look at this from nakamura a massive
blunder he's walked into a night fork a
basic night fork the black king attacked
the black rook attacked and nakamura is
about to resign he's losing a rook and
giri celebrates look at that gary
lifting his arms up he takes the win you